Éric Ciotti bonsoir bonsoir je suis très
content de mettre enfin un visage sur le
côté obscur de Nicolas Sarkozy
maintenant voici Tom villa mon stagiaire
[Musique]
c'est pour moi fan bah oui c'est pour
vous voilà parce que je tenais à vous le
dire Thierry je suis fan de vous et je
trouve qu'on dit jamais assez aux gens
qu'on aime qu'on les aime non mais c'est
vrai et puis avec le début de semaine
qu'on a eu print c'est Billy Paul je
préfère le faire maintenant
aidez-moi vivant
j'ai regardé Thierry qu'est-ce qui a
marqué rose
le joueur de foot
quel beau plateau ce soir Thierry
musique
[Musique]
évidemment vous le savez c'est pour
rendre hommage aux chantres de la
déconne de la fête et de l'humour Éric
Ciotti alors
ça va Eric ça va très bien
j'arrive dans 2 minutes je m'occupe des
autres d'abord Patrick Sébastien 40 ans
de télé il a connu l'aménagère de 50 ans
quand elle en avait 10 ça peut ça peut
dire très très fort
sérieux aussi
Patrick Sébastien animateur artiste
écrivain comédien Patrick sous Césaire
festifs c'est quand même à découvrir
talent sans lui on n'aurait pas connu
Dupontel du jardin Shirley Dino Jeff
panacloc bon Shirley Dino ça aurait pas
été une grosse paire non sur le point
auditif parce que la meuf elle parle en
ultrason je suis allé pas humoristeuse
de dauphin Marino
Patrick vous avez dit j'étais déjà
ringard à 25 ans ouais vous avez
d'autres points communs avec François
Hollande
[Applaudissements]
on en a plein
en tout cas Patrick bienvenue à Salut
les Terriens mettez-vous à l'aide soyez
détendu faites comme chez vous et puis
vous avez vu il y a un groupe si vous
voulez jouer ils peuvent faire ce que
vous voulez les gremans bon évidemment à
part casser du noir alors
Santa du groupe iPhone iPhone bonsoir
bonsoir bienvenue Bienvenue merci comme
ça deux fois ça va être bien faire chier
ouais j'ai tout répéter comme ça deux
fois ça ça a bien fait chier
vous êtes la leader du groupe iPhone
iPhone voilà alors parce que Samsung
c'était trop grillé et non mais c'est
vrai que c'est bien de répéter deux fois
iPhone parce que ça rentre mieux c'est
vrai que d'ailleurs Eric vous devriez
faire ça dans votre partie les
républicains républicains on essaye non
mais parce que ça permettrait de faire
la différence entre les républicains et
républicains comme vous et les
républicains démocrates comme Juppé donc
Santa vous êtes originaire de Nice et
vous avez dit Nice c'est la ville idéale
pour composer tu m'étonnes avec le
nombre de vues à moitié sourds tu peux
répéter
Éric Ciotti bonsoir bonsoir je suis très
content de mettre enfin un visage sur le
côté obscur de Nicolas Sarkozy
Eric vous êtes député les républicains
alors vous savez que vous êtes le seul à
quoi vous êtes présenté à la primaire
sur les arc-en-ciel qu'est-ce qu'il fait
le même la femme de ménage à la fin
vous avez vu la liste Thierry ils sont
11 candidats en tout cas si vous devez
choisir celui qui a le moins de
casserole locus ça va être chaud enfin
bon en tout cas il paraît qu'erisiotti
il est tellement contre la mixité que
vous comptez remplacer les olives noires
par des olives vertes dans la salade
niçoise
Éric en tant que président du conseil
départemental des Alpes-Maritimes ou
pousser un coup de gueule contre les
flux migratoires incontrôlés et je suis
entièrement d'accord avec vous voilà non
vraiment moi je le pense faudrait fermer
les frontières mais entre le 1er juillet
et le 30 août comme ça plus d'allemand
plus de Hollandais et plus d'anglais sur
la Côte d'Azur qui nous vole notre rosée
et nos salades niçoise
mesdames et messieurs je suis ici pour
vous poser les questions trop con que
Thierry Ardisson n'a pas voulu vous
poser
Santa vous avez longtemps fait vos
répétitions avec votre groupe dans le
dans le salon de vos parents c'est vrai
c'est vrai et du coup vos parents ils
habitaient dans le garage
[Rires]
Eric Ciotti
Eric vous êtes l'auteur d'une
proposition de loi visant à lutter
contre l'absentéisme scolaire et du coup
quand vous regardez énergie 12 vous avez
pas de sentiment d'avoir échoué un peu
un petit peu un peu
[Musique]
et pour terminer Patrick Sébastien vous
aviez sorti un livre dans lequel vous
vous évoquez vos expériences dans des
clubs échangistes alors sans citer de
nom est-ce que sur ce plateau il y a des
gens que vous avez connu dans voilà non
émission bon courage et pour être sûr de
ne rien rater de Inna larditube
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu